[Music]
you know someone who wants to taper off
caffeine I'm not doing a very good job
having an espresso machine right next to
my desk is very dangerous and probably a
stupid idea so you know it's pretty
crazy the human brain is pretty crazy
it's such a fascinating machine and we
barely have scratched the surface of
what it's capable of but for that very
reason we don't really understand it
fully like why is it that some days it
seems like our friend like we're full of
confidence full of energy witty sharp is
attack while other days it feels like
our enemy you know feels you feel with
Erick you feel sluggish feels like
someone just poured over a vat of
molasses over your brain and it's just
slowing down all the gears of your mind
and on these days it seems to completely
sabotage our ability to focus or
remember in the short term or even the
long term basically it just screws over
our brain completely this dilapidated
state is often referred to as brain fog
and according to the internet is
characterized primarily by a lack of
mental clarity inability to focus and a
decreased function of working memory but
why does this happen and how can we
prevent it over the past couple of years
I've been trying to answer this question
because brain fog sucks especially if
you have an important meeting or a date
or you're interacting with people a lot
of the time or you have to solve a
problem a lot of days you can't afford
to be in this state of brain fog you're
presenting to the world like the worst
possible version of yourself and it's
annoying so in this video we're gonna go
over three powerful strategies to clear
up that mental but we're gonna go over
three reasons why you probably have
brain fog and how to fix them how to fix
them how to fix them gotta catch them
all factor number one is over
stimulation I think it was Tim Ferriss
who said that we live in a digital
environment where attention is currency
all these different companies all these
different websites these advertisers
they want your attention because they
can monetize it whenever you click on
something somebody gets paid whenever
you watch something somebody gets paid
even on this channel I have ads before
my videos unless you have ad blocker and
turned it off
the case that's fine I'm not picky about
it I'm making like six dollars off these
videos anyways moral of the story is
everybody wants your attention what this
means for you is if you spend a lot of
time on the internet and around screens
inevitably your attention is going to be
completely dispersed in a thousand
different directions and if you spend a
long enough time doing this you start to
get used to having your attention
fragmented YouTube is a perfect example
of this clickbait on YouTube is so
powerful because of something called
super normal stimulus I'll put a link in
the description to my favorite comic on
this there's actually I mean I don't
read comics too often but there's
actually a really really good comic on
super normal stimulus what it is and how
you can fix it or not fix it it's just a
phenomenon it's a psychological
phenomenon improvement pill has a
YouTube channel called the dopamine fast
or it's about a dopamine fast it talks
about a having a single day where you
drink nothing but water and you and you
yeah you don't you don't intake any
information you can only output
information this is obviously a very
extreme example and if you don't live
like a Shaolin monk you probably have
errands to run on a Saturday so you
probably don't have time to do nothing
all day like a scheduled day where you
do nothing but it is a really cool
concept and I still think you should
check the video out but what I think is
a lot more practical of a solution is to
practice meditation I know I talk about
meditation all the time but it's so
powerful in this day and age because
people can't sit still with themselves
for more than five minutes and it trains
you to collect this scattered focus of
yours and redirect it into doing
something super boring
what's more boring than sitting there by
yourself doing nothing and after you
develop this muscle of being able to do
that you can focus on conversations
better you'll be able to focus on a math
problem so reducing social media use bad
screen time and learning how to meditate
or just focusing on doing something
slower pace for an extended period of
time
you will train yourself to stop being so
scattered so foggy so in your head and
really focus in on what's in front of
you it'll help with your brain fog a lot
so one of the best ways to clear up that
brain fog and become more present and
focus and dialed in is to prevent being
scattered in the first place say you
have to write a paper and the deadline
is one month from now you have some
clear days where you could work on your
paper but you say to yourself oh it's
due a month from now I can definitely do
it three weeks before and then three
weeks before it comes and you're like I
can do it two weeks before every time
you do that you're not forgetting about
this deadline you're just giving it to
your subconscious to worry about and the
more things your subconscious has to
worry about the more scattered you
become just because it isn't on the
front lines of your brain and the thing
that you're actively thinking about all
the time you're still thinking about it
subconsciously you're worrying about it
and the more things you give to your
subconscious to worry about the worse
your brain fog gets so just get it done
so you don't have to worry about it
anymore and you can just focus on the
task at hand so tip number one is don't
procrastinate and tip number two is to
write down your goals objectives and
tasks say you meet a friend on the
street that you haven't seen for a while
and you catch up you have a great
conversation and they say hey let's meet
up Tuesday afternoon and let's grab
lunch and you say yeah that sounds like
a great idea I'll see you then and then
you depart you depart I said that
archaically you depart from each other
write that down schedule it in set a
reminder on your phone so that you can
forget about it don't give it to your
subconscious to have to worry about
you're just gonna be thinking Tuesday
afternoon I've got a dinner dinner date
Tuesday afternoon I've got a lunch date
with Kevin and that makes your attention
to everything else for that entire week
reduced because you're just gonna be
thinking about this lunch date with
Kevin you have to remember this is dumb
every time that you have a task to do
every time you have something scheduled
you agree to something write it down set
a reminder on your phone so that you can
forget about it it'll free up mental RAM
and it'll bring your your subconscious
super you have going on it'll reduce the
ingredients of that soup giving you a
nice clear broth that will help your
brain operate better it's so hot in here
I look terrible whole take it from
somebody who has struggled through
anxiety his entire life it's pretty much
conquered it not having things to worry
about
completely reduces your exact
not completely I can't diagnose you and
say like oh yeah if you schedule your
day your anxiety disorder will go away
that's not what I'm saying I'm saying
that you're doing yourself a lot of
favors if you become more organized you
don't procrastinate you have less things
to worry about in general so tip number
two is all about being on top of things
okay factor number three is general
health this one's not going to be a long
one there's a million videos on how to
optimize your health going to sleep on
time waking up at a decent hour getting
enough sleep all that yada yada yada
I have a million videos about sleep
actually I probably only have two
whatever for most people that means
between seven and nine hours of sleep
per night or seven and a half and eight
and a half hours of sleep per night stay
hydrated eat good food and exercise
everybody knows these things but almost
nobody does all of them correctly so if
you feel like you've tried everything to
reduce brain fog and you haven't tried
to optimize your health you're doing
yourself a huge disservice and the
biggest one of all of these probably in
my experience is getting exercise
there's a video from a channel called
what I've learned about the cognitive
benefits of exercise in this video he
talks about how whenever someone talks
about the benefits of exercise they talk
about reduced heart disease and maybe
the ability to you know not get a stroke
when you're older it's all basically
exercise isn't sold very well almost
nobody talks about the cognitive
benefits that you receive from exercise
if exercise was sold in a pill it would
be the best selling pill ever
be the closest thing to NZT 48 you could
possibly find I've started weightlifting
five days a week over the past couple of
weeks and I'm gonna continue to do so
mostly because it makes me feel amazing
and I'm not even talking about my bodily
energy I'm talking about my mental
energy I'm on the ball these days I
don't know if you could tell but I'm
just like I'm sick these days I tribute
a lot of that to exercise my diet hasn't
changed much I've been eating more
protein and I've been staying hydrated
but there's something about exerting
yourself every single day it's almost
like your body and mind learned that
you're an energetic person and it gives
you all this energy for free it's
amazing so that's about it guys if you
take all three of these factors into
account
I guarantee you unless there's something
seriously wrong with you and you need to
see a doctor your brain fog will
significantly reduce you'll become a
focused tiger
ten times more attractive five times
more focused three times more productive
and one times more yourself and probably
less friends because they'll all be
jealous okay guys before you go I have
relaunched my patreon by being my patron
not only do you get to support the
channel and help me make better idea
better ideas I mean yeah their ideas
videos but you help me make better
videos in general all you need to be is
a $1 patron to unlock my vlog but there
are two more tiers of rewards if you
become a tier 2 patron the doer you
unlock the bi-weekly livestream which is
specifically dedicated to answering your
questions
live in front of the camera you might
also get to see me play player unknowns
battlegrounds or fortnight or whatever
you guys suggest it's a rarity I don't
play very many video games these days
but it could happen and the final tier
if you become a level 3 patron you're
just the greatest human being who ever
lived I would appreciate you like no one
else I would favour your opinion over
everyone else's I would love you more
it's basically just a really good gig
for you I also am guaranteed to record a
heartfelt thank you message address
directly to you and I'll include your
name in the description of every single
video so click the link and you enjoy
some of the coolest benefits that you've
ever experienced on a youtube channel
and finally if you're not part of the
Facebook group already it's one of the
most boppin Facebook groups I've ever
been a part of people are posting all
the time we have a group chat people are
casually asking questions it's fantastic
the link for that is in the description
as well thanks for watching and we'll
catch you in the next video